my
sacred mission is to create the perfect
Society
what is Disney trying to say here the
writers of Disney put this in there that
no there is some kind of agenda in here
why is the story about perfection and it
can't be possible there's no way this is
just pure coincidence that every movie
is a fight against Perfection and a
Creator and it's like how many times
does this scenario end up and it's more
concerning why are people spending money
to watch it
yeah
so I think it's very interesting there's
a new movie that came out called
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 this is
version three yeah and it just came out
and the fascinating thing about this
thing is as I was looking at the trailer
I realized that they're going towards a
specific agenda here this
is what's happening and I've seen this
same agenda happen in many many
different movies
can I show you what that is yeah so
check this out this is the this is a
clip from Guardians of Galaxy 3 and
three other movies and see if you can
see what they're doing in all these
movies check this out
we have but a single quest to create the
perfect species and the perfect Society
I'm not trying to conquer the universe
I'm perfecting it did you know that the
first Matrix
was designed to be a perfect human world
you are clue I am clue you will create
the perfect system I will create the
perfect system I'm going to Grant you
greatest wish
I'm going to show you a world without
sin
oh maybe on another world maybe on this
very round swept clean a year from now
10 they'll swing back to the belief they
can make people
better
[Music]
and I do not hold to that
so no more running
I am to misbehave I aim to misbehave
that's what that guy said at the very
end now that last movie might not have
known very much because it's not a
well-known movie but if you remember
Scotty this was the movie I brought on a
USB drive at Weimar when you did the
presentations and I said look at this
this is weird why are they presenting
all this stuff in here this is the one I
do actually remember you you've given me
this movie but I don't know if I ever
looked at it but I do remember you kind
of like talking about it 10 years ago or
more actually now what's the name of the
movie so this was called Serenity it's
basically Serenity series called Firefly
interesting yeah so but the premise of
the whole movie is this that these guys
is a sci-fi movie and they tried to go
and uh fight against this Galactic force
that was trying to make worlds perfect
and it was messing everybody up and so
they they it destroy destroyed everyone
wow so that's interesting so
consistently the Lynn is the one looking
for Perfection wanting Perfection acting
uh all its actions is leading towards
Perfection and it's the heroes that are
fighting against that exactly and that's
what he said yeah I Am The Bisbee what
is this Star Wars we're the Rebellion it
just seems like a sad sad existence if
you can't imagine a world without sin
you know what I mean like like this is
this is this is a world where these
people would would think that that would
be evil if there was a world with what
you couldn't do something bad one of
those movies actually used sin as a
terminology yeah and that's this one and
you would think that this one wasn't uh
you know talking about any type of moral
in it this is a unique movie though
because all the others are talking about
Evolution and this one is very religious
but they all are fighting against this
idea of a perfect Society why why yeah
the Matrix was like yeah I think it
fights against what Christianity's end
goal is is a world with no tears no pain
it's not just that like we're really
really kidding ourselves because no
Society could work with that chaos yet
we love sitting down and watching it so
it's okay to watch it as if it's not
affecting us right but then you step out
of the theater and you have to follow
the laws that are on that state or that
country and you know if you want to keep
a job you better follow the code of
conduct of the company and all these
things well it's funny like a parent you
know you you don't want your children
being disobedient you don't like that
you know it's like nobody likes that but
yet here we talk about this in our
society all the time they're like we
don't know what to follow the rules all
those rules here kids watch Frozen
Disobedience for me why
are they so disobedient yeah so so let's
go through each one of these movies just
real quick and look at what they said if
you think that those unique clips that I
collage together are just a one-time off
and throughout the moment we know this
is a theme throughout the entire movie
these are different clips in the same
movies that are talking about the same
thing now let's let's just look over the
Matrix
the first Matrix I designed was quite
naturally perfect it was a work of art
Flawless Sublime Flawless sounds like
somewhere I would like to be
so so the first Matrix and we we know
what happened in The Matrix right they
said well according to the fourth one if
you read through the uh the transcript
of what happened in the fourth one it
says this it says that they were trying
the machines were trying to make a
perfect Society for people but they
realize that the people didn't want
Perfection they couldn't live in
Perfection well even in the first one he
calls The Matrix and says I want to
create a world with no rules a world
without you and you're scared of us and
all this stuff I know that you're afraid
you're afraid of us you're afraid of
change I'm going to show them a world
without you a world without rules and
controls Without Borders or boundaries a
world where anything is possible now
this is Tron Tron is uh another movie we
just saw but watch what he says here a
program designed to create a perfect
world am I still to create the perfect
system
yeah yeah you're
serious and and all of a sudden there's
a rebellion that occurs it seems that
this is played out in real life at one
time yeah it seems like the whole Bible
is based on this same idea you know
before before
um I saw some of your presentations 13 I
don't know how many years ago now my
father and I as a youngster would always
come out of the movie and say this we'd
always say why is that there's no new
story is there it's always the story of
a savior saving the world why is that we
never put two and two together that it
was almost a reverse of that yeah and
yeah and that was a big aha moment for
me is when I realized wait a second the
good guy is the bad guy and the bad guy
is the good guy in most of the movies
I've watched according to the
characteristics presented yeah I think
it's it's kind of like when you look at
some of the stories the Bible the Bible
has a lot of like really terrible things
in it right but you can actually see
Jesus in a lot of these stories even in
the characters in the Old Testament and
and so you know when God looks at that
individual he sees the life of his son
and I think the devil's just
counterfeiting that he's just telling
his version of the story and there
really is another any other story he's
interested in telling and so it's like
all this rebellion and you know fighting
against this government or rules or you
know and it's all presented a different
way like the Matrix it was I will create
the perfect system in Serenity it was
the perfect society and and uh regarding
Galaxy it was a perfect world but if you
take a step back what's the end message
they're wanting you to leave you with it
doesn't work that's literally the the
punch line of all these things and
the the people they're fighting against
in Serenity is this guy check this out
I believe in something greater than
myself
a better world
a world without sin that's the bad guy
so that's the bad guy talking wow a
world without sin he believes and that's
the guy they're fighting against so so
you when you say the bad guy you mean
like in a in a uh Christian sense
they're portraying him as the bad guy
but really it's a it's a representation
of God yeah well I I mean essentially
Because he believes in a world without
sin but in the movie he's the one
defeated by the main character he's
villainized yeah one of the X-Men X-Men
apocalypse so it's called apocalypse and
the the villain says he's he's Yahweh
and he's like I've come to cleanse the
Earth I've been called many things over
many lifetimes Krishna
Yahweh together we will cleanse the
Earth it's like Satan is not coming to
cleanse the Earth and and he's you know
he's not coming as Yahweh and all these
things
it's interesting because a lot of times
people say well maybe this is
maybe it's an antichrist like character
or something maybe it's the bad guy is
he has a God complex or something what
would you think about that
yeah you know I I think that there's a
lot of terminology here that just gets
slid in here I mean why would you you
know for what context I didn't see the
movie but what context would you bring
up the word sin right I mean it just has
such a a strong connection to the Bible
I don't know it's just outside of that
Satan is not coming to wipe away sin
yeah you know it's like make a perfect
Society in any kind of way we almost
need to Define what sin is because I
think even the movie tries to skew that
a little bit but let's look at a movie
that has recently come out called
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 and see if it
has that same theme oh
I will destroy your entire civilization
as is my right as your makeup so he's
the maker of the society and he says
it's his right to destroy them wow
which
for being honest yes it is his right but
the way they're portraying it is as if
he's enjoying it or he wants to do it
when when you look in the Bible it hurts
God to have to address sin and and it's
in when he does address it it's really
for our good it's for our edification so
I'm willingness portrayal yeah he's not
willing that any should perish but that
all should come to repentance and right
I think right before that is talking
about yes don't considering no pleasure
in the death of the wicked yeah and it
says you know don't consider his
uh long suffering like he's delaying or
he's slacking no he's a long suffering
he's like he'd come right now but how
many people would be lost he's giving
each person no that person is going to
make a decision in a year that one's
going to make a decision 10 years you
know he's full of mercy and Grace which
is what's keeping him from coming but if
you're not on his side
then you will be destroyed and and that
that's how they're painting the villain
like he's
he's God but
in the eyes of Satan and all those who
are lost because they're going to be
destroyed a lot of people who love D
away from Christianity when you ask them
what does God look like or you know if
you say God what picture comes to mind
it's usually a bad relationship that's
in their life authoritarian
authoritarian or maybe something they
viewed on screen but if we would just go
to God's word his voice and actually
hear his perspective and how he speaks
you can kind of hear the pain in his
voice whenever it comes to him having to
reprimand his people yeah definitely I
uh and what I think is fascinating about
this whole thing is that not only do you
have a perfect society that they're
they're writing a movie about but they
also are saying that the entity that is
the villain is coming to destroy the
society and that's in every single movie
let's take for instance the uh the new
movie Guardians of the Galaxy can I just
comment on something I can't quite tell
from this image but is he wearing purple
and blue
he's wearing purple yeah what's the
significance of that I mean blue you
know I I guess maybe it just looks good
with this skin but it's like those are
Sanctuary colors and yeah the blue
represents the Law of purples royalty so
he represents royalty and the law you
should make sure I wonder if they
actually have any scene in there that
would that would relay that does this
stuff look fake to you what do you mean
like like when you watch these modern
movies I don't know if it's the refresh
rate on the TV or something like but it
just looks cheesy like pasty does it
look cheesy to you it's not like the old
movies used to look like the Cinematic
real look this looks like y'all super
Digi yeah it looks like a made for TV
type movie yeah doesn't it I notice that
all the time when I go into Best Buy
sorry a little side tangent like what in
the world this just looks fake how do
people like this okay watch watch this
clip anything I've done I've done
bunch of octopus
octopus and meth to guys with cockroach
heads
they don't know
which is why as I've done many times
before I'm going to have to raise it all
and start again what
kind of monster Slaughters of
civilization what kind of monster
slatters a civilization
you I think that there that their
premise of why this is happening is
faulty to begin with
um you know in the sense of anybody that
would look at God as like that's that's
that's really mean and cruel hearted to
him right the devil's the real master
deflecting who the responsibility is
really at he's the one that's causing
the pain and the suffering and the all
this Gods doesn't want any of us to have
pain and suffering and and in order to
not let that progress throughout
eternity he's willing to to allow you
the choice if you choose not to follow
him then you know he gives you your way
and then he stops that and I I look
forward to a day that he stops that but
it's the devil's fault that this stuff
is happening yeah and where's the finger
pointing at him right right I remember
seeing the uh you actually showed me the
trailer for this movie and it's like all
the good guys are just surrounded by
fire there's like fire all around him
and they're like we got this is like one
last war or whatever are you ready for
one last ride and they actually say they
think of him as a god
sound corners of the universe consider
him God they said there's a whole race
of people that think of him as a God so
they're literally calling him God and
the closed caption is a capital G too I
don't know you know just the fact that
he's God is he is he a Creator too he
created that he created racialization
yeah so the the idea from the summary I
got about the movie is that they um this
guy wanted to create a perfect side
Society from the evolution of uh
creating these these half human half
animal-like creatures and he wanted to
make him happy and so he's making a
perfect society that they don't fight in
and it almost works but he has to raise
and raise means destroy the entire thing
every time that it doesn't work in other
words he made a mistake mistake yeah
he's at fault there was nothing that his
creation could have done you know it's
all on him and as somebody who watches
this they're thinking yeah God he
created the Earth and he had to destroy
it he had in a flood because it didn't
go according to it wasn't perfect so he
had to destroy it and that's but see how
you can how Satan it's 99 truth a little
bit of error it wasn't that God made a
mistake it was Adam and Eve that made a
mistake and that cursed everyone and God
allowed that to play out to the point
where Noah and his family eight people
were the only righteous people worthy of
being saved like that's how long
suffering God is like
it's amazing you know for me truth Works
in a multitude of contexts right so I
hear things like that and it's like
would someone get mad at a stove if it
burned them for them touching it well
you decided to touch it and then it
reacted so and when it comes to sin we
bear the consequences of our decisions
and we shouldn't always be as you're
saying trying to cast the blame on the
the results of our own actions a common
mindset that I hear from atheists is
like you know if God if God exists there
wouldn't be all this pain in the world
and stuff like that but at the at the
same time you point back they would also
say that he's uh
you know unjust for destroying the world
because there was you know women and
children all this stuff and it's like
you can't have it both ways like they
say he it doesn't exist because there's
pain in the world but when there's pain
in the world and he stopped it then they
got a problem with that too so God
really can't win with
people who just don't want to believe
and they don't want to surrender their
lives to him so they
they're confused yeah they'll use one
excuse or the other
and so I've got a few more Clips here
that show that every single movie that
I've picked out here is following the
same pattern and so watch these next few
clips that talk about the destruction
of the society World system or whatever
they want to call it a world without sin
so me and mine kind of lay down and die
so you can live in your Better World all
right now watch this next one this is
the animatrix it's kind of does the pre-
uh requisites for what the Matrix is so
it's it's important to see exactly what
this what is actually saying here
thank you
[Music]
that's
perfect huh gonna Destroy All Flesh
because wow
so hand over your flesh yeah and we're
going to destroy you we'll give you a
better place but we have to destroy the
current one first all right so this is
Tron Tron has the exact same story I
created the perfect system
[Music]
yeah
probably one of my favorite scenes out
of any movie I have to admit I like I
like that final ending was like the uh
was that the same story in the original
70s version or I never saw the original
okay
but um but it is what's fascinating
about that is what had happened was the
bad guy and the god figure the creator
of this system and the bad guy which is
the program he created went rogue
because he told them hey I want you to
create the perfect system
and then he said at the very end
I was wrong I I I didn't know you
couldn't have a perfect system but I
create but what out of my creation came
these evolutionary beings
that came out of nowhere and that was
perfect they cured diseases cured
diseases so we're going to go over that
in a second but I think it's it's
interesting that all these things have
the exact same pattern to them and
that's Satan's argument against God like
nobody can keep your law you know or
whatever
another theme that we have throughout
these entire this entire movie Set
series that he goes from from a perfect
Society
to God destroying that perfect Society
to the answer being Evolution evolution
so watch this these are Clips showing
that exact same thing from these exact
same movies the first one is the Matrix
I see you're a civilization because as
soon as we started thinking for you it
really became our civilization which is
of course what this is all about
Evolution Morpheus
evolution
so it's Evolution and then watch this
next clip that's what I thought it
couldn't get any more profound something
unexpected happened a whole new life
form and you created them
[Music]
no
they manifested like a flame they
weren't really really from anywhere the
conditions were right and they came into
being the possibilities of their root
code their digital DNA disease History
Science philosophy every idea man has
ever had about the universe up the grabs
bio digital Jazz man so what did he say
there he said by the digital Jazz yeah
so what is the very basis that any jazz
player will tell you what it is I have
no clue it's um it's chaos really that's
why that's why jazz is chaos and um
that there's some interesting Concepts
that are brought up here because
evolution is is is like
God created the world we chose to not
follow what God planned and it's falling
apart they're saying the opposite that's
basically like it's evolving into
something better which is really like
not a Biblical picture at all the Bible
describes that this thing's just getting
worse and worse and worse life
spans went down I mean but it's like
yeah we're trying to evolve yeah
evolution is almost the opposite
perspective of God
this is the most recent movie Guardians
of the Galaxy same exact story watch
this I've developed a process by which I
can guide any organism through millions
of years of programmed evolutionary
changes
[Music]
oh yeah
Netflix full creatures we always sort
ready to inhabit the new world
ready to inhabit a new world he said and
and and you know what's very interesting
is like what are these guardians of the
galaxies doing they're like coming in
fighting and shooting each other and
being mean to each other and everything
right whereas God's world is a very
symbiotic relationship where everything
gets along I mean the the you know ocean
evaporates and goes into the cloud and
goes over and Waters the plants and you
know the bees pick the pollen off and
and it's you can see the fingerprint of
God Evolution seems to be survival of
the fittest I'm gonna dominate you and
and become the top of the food chain so
the fact that they're creating this
Beast thing out of a an animal and then
it's like now it's going to inhabit the
worlds and and take over basically is is
the opposite perspective of God this
movie got some heat right because of the
animal experimentation yes huge heat
because they were uh they were a lot of
Articles written about this saying that
they they were hurting animals and
obviously they weren't really hurt
animals but they said if you are uh
sensitive to that don't go watch this
shut your eyes yeah and when's the last
time you've seen an article that said
hey beware Deadpool has over 100 deaths
or something we
can kill humans all day long oh you you
talk about an animal we're getting in
the morning
so I thought it'd be a good idea to kind
of Define what it is uh that they're
fighting against here it is it is
absolutely they're saying Humanity needs
to be sinful we need to be leave us
alone you made a mistake God we're we're
sinful beings and we like how we are in
The Matrix when he was describing what
the Matrix was and he said that you know
the first few versions were the perfect
world and then he went and he said that
your the population wouldn't accept it
so they had to allow the faults to come
in just so it would be an accepted
program what
and the Bible clearly says you know all
has sinned and fallen short of the glory
of God and so essentially we as a
society
can't be perfect in that sense of the
word you you have sinned everybody has
sinned except for Jesus
who is perfection who we can look to but
is there does the bible say that we
by looking and be holding upon
Perfection we can be changed by glory to
glory into that yeah absolutely it's
true I think it's interesting I don't
know though I'm not I'm not really
buying this fight against Perfection
thing
um at least from society's standpoint I
think we want Perfection think of when a
child is born or a mother before she has
her child she's wanting a perfect baby
you know four limbs fully functioning
brain think about a train system you
want it to run on time you want a
perfect system working when you buy a
computer don't you want a perfect system
or you know we want a law and order that
level of perfection from you know
societal perspective I think the real
issue is who is
asking for or who is making the thing
perfect
so in these movies uh the person wanting
the Perfection is the villain and for
all the things that they're portraying
you know they're angry and all that yes
in a way the natural thing is to not
like this person
um but when you're looking at God and
why Society is so against or people who
are not Christian are against God and
him wanting Perfection is because of the
conditions that come with it right so
they're wanting the benefit of a perfect
Society without having anything to do
with them or their actions or what have
you or their desires exactly
and so for being honest with us with
ourselves I think that is the root of it
of what we need to do to help with the
Perfection and also really why are we
fighting against the person that is
pushing for the Perfection when it's
really for our good because if I mean we
do want Perfection absolutely yeah I
think sex drugs and rock and roll is
like the three things that make people
reject God they want sex one way or
another whether it's fornication or uh
you know some kind of LGBT and then they
want drugs of one choice or another
whether that's
alcohol marijuana addictions of
television or whatever and rock and roll
music you know those are the things that
really people push back on the most like
don't tell me what I can't watch don't
tell me what I can't listen to don't
don't tell me I can't drink or sleep
with who I want to other than that
people do like Perfection like you said
they want things right and they get mad
when it's not you know let me talk to
the manager this wasn't right Galatians
5 16 says I say then walk in the spirit
and you shall not fulfill the lust of
the flesh so when we were walking in the
spirit we won't be sinning essentially
we are focused on Christ and doing
Christ's things we want I mean think
about it for a second if what what is
sin sin is the transgression of the law
right that's First John 3 4 and 5 uh
whoever commits sin also commits
lawlessness and sin is the transgression
of the law
and you know that he was manifested to
take away our sins and in him there is
no sin so he came and took away our sins
but he doesn't mean that we would
continue sinning so if sin is the
transgression of the Ten Commandments
the law of God
are you lying right now by sitting there
are you are you cheating by are you
uh committing adultery are you by just
sitting in one place so if you're not
sinning sinning In This Moment
a lot of Christians even say this I am
sinning every moment of every day
because I exist in sin wow okay that's
not what it means
if sin is a choice no not and not a not
a a body yeah but even that's
overwhelming you know like having to
make these decisions and thinking you
have to be you us like we need to be
perfect we need to make ourselves
perfect when that is not the case we
have Philippians 4 13 I can do all
things through Christ who gives me the
strength taking that pressure off God is
saying I want to work and give you a new
spirit all you need to do is let me in
and allow for that transformation and as
we go through this life that doesn't
mean that we won't get tempted or that
we won't fall it's the righteous man
that falls but gets up and and continues
on his journey and there is Temptation
all around because as long as we're here
on this Earth before God comes and
cleanses it the devil's still this is
his playground you know and and he's
there it's like you wanna I like what
you said there the verse you didn't
complete the righteous man falls seven
times and gets up I love that and I
forgot to put that one in I I just
remember that in my head but yeah with
temptation all around we can't be
faulted for that you know the the whole
point of showing that we can trust God
is that despite all these things we can
keep our connection with him and he will
be a source of protection a source of
forgiveness and to keep our Perfection
despite what's happening in the world
that's what makes him attractive that's
what gives us peace in all this uh
confusion yeah you're making me think of
First Corinthians 10 13 it says no
temptation has overtaken you except such
as as common to man but God is faithful
who will not allow you to be tempted
beyond what you are able but with the
Temptation we'll also make a way of
Escape that you may be able to Bear it
so he's not saying there's not going to
be Temptation Jesus was tempted probably
in more ways
stronger ways than any of us have been
and it wasn't a sin to be tempted it's
not a sin to be tempted it's a sin to
give in to that Temptation and God's
saying yeah there's temptation but I'm
making a way of Escape so there's your
choice are you going to choose to submit
to the Temptation or surrender to me
allow me to work through you and give
you the strength we can do all things
that includes overcoming sin I I don't
think anyone's going to argue that it's
easy to sin would you agree would you
agree with that statement that's very
easy and I think God is very fair he if
it's easy to get into it then he has to
provide a way that's easy for you to get
out of it and and I mean I think that's
where the the rub kind of happens a lot
of people will will say you know they'll
cite on the thing well we're all sitting
we're all sinning all the time and stuff
but yes but God is you know like you
said he's given us a way out and and you
know through one man all this woe came
into the world but through one man you
get out of all this stuff that's a very
fair God and so it only makes sense that
God would not ask you to stop doing that
if you didn't help provide a way to do
that and at the end of time it says and
Revelation 3 21
I I love that three two one that's all
you got to remember to him who overcomes
overcomes to him overcomes I will grant
to sit with me on my throne and as I
also overcame and sat down with my
father on his throne so Christ said he
overcame the world just as we can
overcome the world so and and how did
Christ do that by cause the community
communion with his father by Prayer by
memorizing scripture he came and was a
physical being just as us on Earth so he
had the same issues the same temptations
that we do and he overcame that and just
as we can it says seven times in
Revelation I think even more it's each
one of the churches it's an overcoming
that to them that overcome I give them
this to them that overcame I gave them
that it says it to each one which I
think is great because it's like that
that that totally relays the information
that looked like nobody is quote unquote
sinless their whole entire life Jesus is
the only one but but you're what you
have have to wrap your mind around is
like is it possible to stop doing that
activity if you smoke cigarettes is it
possible for you to stop Yes tons of
people do that if you are a sex addict
is it possible to stop that yes that is
you know and there's there's a lot of
examples of that
um but those verses say that people
overcame that means that they were doing
those activities in the beginning right
that's something I want to say about you
guys there are a few instances in the
bible where jesus essentially is saying
to us do not judge what I have deemed
perfect
so with that in mind
at the end of time is perfection based
on like a blueprint or like a cookie
cutter thing or does God look at each
person and he has his level of
perfection in each person
and access says that he Winks at our
sins committed an ignorance so I think
there's some people that you may look at
and say oh that person's not perfect
because I do this and that but are they
aware of that that's even a sin so I in
that situation God would say this
person's perfect because yeah even
though they're doing that sin they're
not even aware of it now it's our job to
seek that truth out you know and and our
job to share that truth so if we see
that we should you know share that truth
with somebody because it says uh when
the light of truth comes it commands all
to repent I've heard some people say
it's a journey of a lifetime and compare
it to
fruit so in other words I mean God
compares to a fruit but if you imagine a
tomato plant as it's growing is it since
it's not bearing fruit yet and it's just
about this tall is it not perfect is it
not good well no it's perfect in in its
stature as it's growing up but if it's
all the way grown like the fig tree that
Christ saw and it's not bearing fruit
well then it's not perfect it's not good
but if that tomato plant is uh it's
fully grown and bearing fruit
it's perfect pick the fruit off of it
fantastic it's time to harvest and so I
don't think you can ever look at one
individual and say
you know let's be judgmental and say
that they haven't reached the top or the
opposite or the opposite because I think
a concern is that oh look at that person
they're so righteous compared to me and
so I can possibly get up to that you
know what forget Perfection I don't want
to do it at all it's like no we
shouldn't even be comparing ourselves to
each other we should be focusing on a
relationship with Christ I love that
example of the tomato plant yeah and
Jesus is the only one that the Bible
says is sinless but there are multiple
people that he called perfect and
upright that's right Joe Moses Abraham
was perfect and upright so clearly
perfect doesn't mean you're sinless
because
they all sinned we all sin and fall
short of the glory of God because
nobody can reach the point of
accountability and say they've never
sinned when you're a kid you've lied
when you you broke something you lied to
your parents you hurt somebody we're all
Sinners but there can come a point to
where you have such a close relationship
with God that those things sinful Things
Are disgusting to you that I used to
love sexual immorality alcohol marijuana
now all those things repulse me and
that's only because of my relationship
with Christ will I never sin again
no it's probably going to happen but in
those times we have an advocate with a
father if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
cast them as far as the East is to the
west but I don't have a desire to do it
again it'll happen less and less and
less until it's finally gone from your
life because that's what Christ wants he
wants it completely gone for your life
so he can come back
to Earth I mean we we as Christians
want to be with Christ and the only way
we can be in a back in heaven
is to have that character and and Christ
isn't going to come and he's not going
to come and say oh let me fix your
character in your head you know we're
taking that character to heaven so we
need to be ready and you've heard this
all your life be ready be ready be ready
what is that being what does that mean
that said the prayer or whatever yeah
that's that's that's us working with God
is nothing we can do you know it's
Christ working in us but we have to
accept that work and so it's it's very
literal just as you you've talked about
marijuana sex alcohol no very very
interesting so I think it's interesting
that these movies are fighting against
that exact thing the whole time I want
to play my my uh one of my uh
uh favorite Clips because I think it's
uh it kind of encompasses this whole
thing it's not my favorite because
it's right it's it's it's
so blatant how much error is in this and
it's it's based uh because it's Disney
it's Tron watch this you'll pick it up
immediately you don't look so bad
let me see everything you ever asked I
know you did I executed the plan
as you saw it you you promised that we
would change the world together
you broke your promise I know I
understand that now I took this system
to its maximum potential I created the
perfect system the thing about
perfection
is that it's unknowable he said it's
unknowable it's unknowable what is
Disney trying to say here the writers of
Disney put this in there the the god
figure says that Perfection is
unknowable and she had to learn that
story is the guy with the the yellow is
that God the guy or he's Satan the gun
okay so in the movie The God character
is portrayed by the white-haired man
okay to look like an older gentleman who
created this the one on the left yeah so
so this would be a representation of the
devil yeah this would be more agnostic
Jesus well or a person that he created
to manage the entire system that's
that's his his idea I'm sorry I feel
like you just lost half the audience if
you have no idea what we're talking
about I highly suggest you go watch end
game uh Marvel not Satan's end game
Scotty really breaks down what he means
by agnostic Jesus versus uh the villain
being God and all of that but that would
be too much for yeah
yeah so yeah it's just like a complete
twisting and distorting because like
like I said it's almost hard to tell
like who's who but that's what Satan
wants to do confused Babylon that's all
it is he wants to confuse and if you're
watching this saying oh it's just it's
just pure entertainment no there is some
kind of agenda in here why is the story
about perfection and it can't be
possible and this and that why is that
even part of the story it's just like
there's no way this is just pure
coincidence that every movie is a fight
against Perfection and a Creator and
it's like how many times does this
particular scenario end up it's more
concerning why are people spending money
to watch it because that's why they keep
doing it if it didn't work they wouldn't
do it it wouldn't sell and we're always
rooting for the bad guy yeah essentially
yeah I also think that that we all at
least in the in the US you know we kind
of know the basics of of the spiritual
warfare like a lot of people have heard
of God a lot of people have heard of the
devil a lot of people if you said the
Creator people would generally know who
you're talking about and so it has the
buzz words but then they just Tinker
with it in the storyline
so let's watch the rest of the clip what
he says here
it's impossible but it's also right in
front of us all the time Evolution you
wouldn't know that because I did when I
created you oh mistake
I'm sorry
that's a first god scene sorry yeah and
so God
apologizes
to his creation due to the mistakes that
he made that's the seed that's planted
in your head even though that the movie
isn't exactly saying hey you know this
is a a representation of the Gospel
every single movie is playing the same
story out saying hey look Evolution's
the right way God was wrong he's a
tyrant he's a terrible man and that
evolution is the right way he's going to
destroy everybody they go a step further
because now even though all that's been
established those who are deemed the
innocent ones who couldn't help
themselves still get destroyed
we get it so it's like God says sorry
he's the one taking accountability but
yet he's still going to punish and
Destroy that's a terrible figure
wow and it's all about being born this
way you know Lucifer like you created me
God you created me and I had this Pride
come with my heart and I fell and all
this why can't I go to heaven and then
like God's saying I'm sorry I created
you but you're really a woman trapped in
a man's body like all these ideologies
of born this way and it's God's fault
but it's not it's just our own flesh our
own
sinful desires that we struggle with all
of us struggle with it in some form or
another might not be gender confusion or
addictions but we all have are you gonna
lie when that person asks you that
question that tough question
you know is it really something that's
been
different in our day and age the devil
really been doing this since the
beginning I mean Jesus had to come to
write the perspective of God because
over time we lost who God was it seems
like he's shrouded the truths in mystery
and and by all the different you know
gods and things that he's had Humanity
fall prey to worshiping Jesus had to
come back and be like no that's not what
God's like and it's like he's still
doing the same thing today the devil is
spreading Mass misinformation
about God who he is he's the Creator did
the devil create us no he didn't so you
can't look at that story right there
because that's the devil you know what I
mean it's like you can only look at that
one way that's God and you know I find
it just interesting that they keep
hammering at this idea it's God's fault
that's a really good question like you
know Satan been doing this or is this a
new tactic it might be a new tactic it's
like think about it before Jesus came
the Jews were expecting a God to come
and and save them but save them like be
the Conquering King right get rid of the
Romans and you know they were going to
be at the top they'll be wealthy and all
of that which was an incorrect view of
God and nowadays as you said we're
expecting a god actually we don't want
him to come and when he does come we're
expecting him to wipe out everything
it's still a wrong view of God but it's
different from from the time of when the
Jews were there and and Jesus came to
this earth
at the end of the day
no matter how it's portrayed it's a
wrong portrayal and Satan I don't know I
don't know what he uses as the barometer
as to how he's going to portray him this
time around but we know where to get the
right portrayal right and that's found
in the Bible and that's really our
Saving Grace that's that's where we
should be going for information and the
only way to be able to pick out those
buzzwords and to pick out the the
inconsistencies with truth is to know
the truth is to go to the Bible which is
why a lot of people don't see it even
when we pointed out they want to deny it
or whatever one of the final verses I
think is is important to think about is
Ecclesiastes 12 9-14 the portion of that
says let us hear the conclusion of the
whole matter fear God and keep his
Commandments for this is the whole duty
of man the entire duty of man is the
fear God to keep his commands and I
think that's that's
it I mean because if
if sin is the transgression of The
Commandments the law
then the whole duty of man is just to
hate don't lie be nice to your neighbor
and be nice to God love your neighbor
love your God and that's that's the
whole duty of man love
sounds good to me amen longboard right
hey if you appreciated this program give
us a like subscribe and a comment and
tell us what you thought about it yeah
and if you really want to support this
ministry you can do so by going to
patreon.com Little Light Studios we
cannot do this without you guys and we
love you we'll see you next time on LED
live
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there
has been very few movies in the history
of the world that have completely
changed our world and in 1999 a movie
titled The Matrix hit the world stage
these stories are often told and seen
over and over again is it simply just to
make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank
you